THE SENATE WILL COME TO ORDER.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA
ASHBY. ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. DALLY DODD. DURAZZO.
EGGMAN. GLASER GONZALEZ. GROVE.
HURTADO. JONES LAIRD. LEMON.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR MIN. NEWMAN.
NGUYEN. NILO OCHOA. BOGUE.
PADILLA. PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO.
SATO. SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
STERN. UMBERG. WAHAB. WIENER
WILK. A QUORUM IS PRESENT. GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE. WITH THE
MEMBERS AND THE GUESTS. BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY,
PLEASE RISE. WE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY OUR
GUEST CHAPLAIN, REVEREND BOB.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. REVEREND
. PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
QUIET REFLECTION. THERE ARE OVER
40 COUNTRIES AND CULTURES IN THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLAND AREA. THEIR
CULTURAL INFLUENCE ON THE WORLD
STAGE IS NOW A NATURAL PART OF
OUR EVERYDAY LIFE. IN THE AREAS
OF ART, MUSIC, DANCE,
LITERATURE, FOOD, PHILOSOPHY,
SPIRITUALITY, ECONOMICS AND
POLITICS, IN EVERY DIMENSION OF
OUR LIVES, WE HAVE A FUSION OF
CULTURAL FLAVORS AND IT IS
WONDERFUL. IT IS BOTH BEAUTIFUL
AND MEANINGFUL TO TAKE PRIDE IN
THE CULTURES AND TRADITIONS
WITHIN WHICH WE HAVE BEEN
RAISED. EVEN MORE BEAUTIFUL IS
IT TO TAKE PRIDE IN THE
MULTICULTURAL HERITAGE THAT, IN
ESSENCE, WE ALL SHARE HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND
MOST ESPECIALLY IN BEING A PART
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA?
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE ABOUT 200
COUNTRIES RECOGNIZED BY THE
UNITED NATIONS IN THE WORLD
TODAY, IN REALITY, WE ARE NOT
SEPARATE. WE ARE ALL ONE
HUMANITY IN THE BORDERLESS
GEOGRAPHY OF THE EARTH. WITH A
VISION OF THE WORLD AS ONE, WE
WILL BEGIN TO LIVE WITH EMPATHY
AND KINDNESS. CGRTS AS WE
REALIZE WE ARE ALL CONNECTED IN
THE FABRIC OF LIFE. TODAY IS A
REMINDER FOR US TO EMBRACE AND
APPRECIATE THE BEAUTY OF
DIVERSITY. NAMEMY DOUBTS WITH
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS. REVEREND, THANK YOU FOR
BEING WITH US TODAY. MEMBERS AND
GUESTS, PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE. TO THE REPUBLIC FOR
WHICH IT STANDS. ONE NATION
UNDER GOD, INDIVISIBLE, LIBERTY
AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
MEMBERS. LET ME JUST GIVE YOU A
FLAVOR FOR THE DAY TODAY. WE
HAVE SOME WONDERFUL
PRESENTATIONS AND INTRODUCTIONS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE. WE
HAVE ABOUT EIGHT BILLS ON THE
AGENDA FOR OUR REVIEW. SO
MEMBERS, WITHOUT OBJECTION, WE
WILL TAKE UP THE FOLLOWING
RESOLUTION. OUT OF ORDER TODAY.
THIS IS FILED ITEM 14 SR 81.
AFTER ADOPTION OF THE RESOLUTION
WILL RETURN TO PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR FOR THE AUTHOR TO
INTRODUCE THEIR GUESTS. SO, TO
BEGIN THE DAY'S PROCEEDINGS,
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR. THIS IS SR 81
BY SENATOR MINH. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ EXCUSE ME. ITEM 14.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
RESOLUTION 81 BY SENATOR MINH,
RELATIVE TO ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICAN HERITAGE
MONTH. SENATOR MINH AT THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE ASIAN AMERICAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS, ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUE,
SENATOR AISHA WAHAB, I'M PLEASED
TO PRESENT SR 81 TO RECOGNIZE
MAY 2024 AS AAPI HERITAGE MONTH.
EACH MAY, OUR COUNTRY CELEBRATES
THE DIVERSITY OF PEOPLE WHOSE
FAMILIES, LIKE MINE, IMMIGRATED
FROM ASIA AND THE PACIFIC
ISLANDS TO AMERICA. APIS ARE ONE
OF THE FASTEST GROWING ETHNIC
POPULATIONS IN THE UNITED STATES
AND IN CALIFORNIA, WITH THIS
STATE BEING HOME TO MORE THAN 7
MILLION ASIAN AMERICAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDERS, COMPRISING
15% OF OUR STATE POPULATION.
THROUGHOUT HISTORY, AAPI HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY CONTRIBUTED TO OUR
NATION'S AND STATE'S
DEVELOPMENT. AND TODAY AND THIS
MONTH, WE CELEBRATE AND EMBODY
THOSE DEEPLY ROOTED CULTURAL
TRADITIONS AND STORIES. WE
REPRESENT A LARGE PORTION OF OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS, SMALL
BUSINESSES, AND FRONTLINES. WE
PROVIDE RESOURCES AND ADVOCATE
FOR THE NEEDS OF DIVERSE AA AND
NHPI POPULATIONS, AND OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE CONTINUED TO
FIGHT FOR EQUITABLE
REPRESENTATION AND ACCESS ACROSS
ALL FIELDS. GROWING UP IN THE
1980S HERE IN CALIFORNIA, I
DIDN'T HAVE A LOT OF ROLE MODELS
TO LOOK UP TO, WHETHER IT WAS IN
POLITICS OR LAW OR BUSINESS OR
MEDICINE OR NONPROFITS OR
PHILANTHROPY. BUT TODAY, BEHIND
ME, WE HAVE A CROSS SECTION OF
LEADERS THAT ARE STARTING TO
FILL OUT THOSE ROLES. AND THAT
IS SO IMPORTANT FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
CELEBRATING ASIAN AMERICAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER HERITAGE MONTH
AND IN SUPPORTING SR 81. THANK
YOU, SENATOR MINH. FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE. SENATOR
NGUYEN. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I TOO RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE RESOLUTION 81,
RECOGNIZING MAY AS ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER HERITAGE MONTH,
WE CELEBRATE AAPI HERITAGE MONTH
TO COMMEMORATE THE ASIAN
AMERICAN PACIFIC ISLANDERS
EXPERIENCE AND TELL THE MANY
STORIES OF INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES WHO CAME TO THE UNITED
STATES AND HAVE CONTRIBUTED
GREATLY TO THE AMERICAN DREAM.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO OVER 6
MILLION ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICANS. MORE THAN
ANY MORE THAN THAN ANY OTHER
STATES. MY COMMUNITY, ORANGE
COUNTY, IS HOME TO THE THIRD
LARGEST NUMBER OF ASIAN-AMERICAN
OWNED BUSINESSES IN THE UNITED
STATES, WITH OVER 63,000 ASIAN
AMERICAN OWNED BUSINESSES
COUNTYWIDE. THE MONTH OF MAY WAS
CHOSEN TO REMEMBER THE
IMMIGRATION OF THE FIRST
JAPANESE TO THE UNITED STATES ON
MAY 7TH, 1843, AND TO MARK THE
ANNIVERSARY OF THE COMPLETION OF
TRANSCONTINENTAL RAILROAD ON MAY
10TH, 1869. THE MAJORITY OF THE
WORKERS WHO LAID THE TRACKS
BEING CHINESE IMMIGRANTS,
CHINESE INDIAN, FILIPINO,
VIETNAMESE, KOREAN, JAPANESE,
HMONG, AND MANY OTHER GROUPS. WE
ARE ALL WE'VE ALL ARRIVED IN
AMERICA. LOW SKILLED, LOW WAGE
LABORERS AND FACING EXTREME
DISCRIMINATION. OUR COMMUNITIES
HAVE MADE AMAZING STRIDES IN
ACHIEVING SUCCESS IN THE
AMERICAN DREAM. BUT THERE IS
STILL MUCH WORK TO BE DONE.
DISCRIMINATION, HATE CRIMES, AND
ASIAN AMERICAN INDUSTRIES THAT
HAVE BEEN SINGLED OUT IN OUR
STATE'S LEGISLATURE. I AM
FIGHTING TO MAKE SURE NOT ONLY
THAT WORK OF THIS IMPORTANT
COMMUNITY IS RECOGNIZED, BUT
THAT WE ARE TREATED FAIRLY.
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING THIS MEASURE SO WE
CAN RECOGNIZE THE MANY AAPI
CONTRIBUTIONS TO CALIFORNIA AND
THE UNITED STATES. I ALSO SAW
THAT THERE IS A BOOKLET ON YOUR
DESK. AS WELL. JUST TO NOTE,
THERE'S ALSO FOUR REPUBLICAN
AAPI MEMBERS, THREE IN THE
STATE, IN THE ASSEMBLY, AND
MYSELF HERE IN THE SENATE, WE
WOULD NOT RECOGNIZE IN THE
BOOKLET. BUT I ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE UNDERSTAND THAT
BEING ASIAN-AMERICAN, YOU'RE
BORN WITH IT. YOU'RE BORN AS AN
ASIAN-AMERICAN. IT'S NOT A
CHOICE. PARTIZANSHIP IS A
CHOICE. YOU CAN BE A REPUBLICAN
OR A DEMOCRAT OR NO PARTY
PREFERENCE. I CHOSE TO RECOGNIZE
TODAY, ASIAN-AMERICAN MONTH, NOT
A PARTIZAN ISSUE AT ALL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR NGUYEN.
NEXT UP, I HAVE SENATOR
BRADFORD, FOLLOWED BY SENATOR
WAHAB. SENATOR BRADFORD, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS, I
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SR 81
RECOGNIZING MAY 2020 FOR AS
ASIAN AMERICAN NATIVE HAWAIIAN
AND PACIFIC ISLANDER HERITAGE
MONTH. AS SOMEONE WHOSE
GRANDPARENTS LIVED IN JAPAN AND
I GREW UP AND STILL LIVE IN
GARDENA, WHICH HAS A STRONG
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER PRESENCE,
AND AS SOMEONE WHO REPRESENTS A
DISTRICT WITH A LARGE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER PRESENCE IN THE
COMMUNITY, I WANT TO RECOGNIZE
THE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT ARE MADE
TO SUSTAIN THIS STATE AS WELL AS
THIS NATION, WHETHER IT WAS
BUILDING OUR RAILROADS UNDER
HARSH, UNJUST AND RACIST
CONDITIONS ARE ON THE THEATER OF
WAR IN WORLD WAR TWO. THE MIGHTY
442. GO FOR BROKE AND THEIR
COURAGE. OR TODAY IN THE FIELDS
OF EDUCATION, SCIENCE,
TECHNOLOGY, ART, ENTERTAINMENT
THAT ADD TO THE RICH TAPESTRY
THAT MAKE UP CALIFORNIA. SO I
STAND IN SOLIDARITY TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THESE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS, ESPECIALLY AS
THIS COMMUNITY HAS COME UNDER
ATTACK IN PLACES SUCH AS, ISSUES
OF RACISM AND IGNORANCE. WE MUST
STRONGLY CONDEMN THIS HATRED AND
CONTINUE TO STAND WITH OUR ASIAN
AMERICAN BROTHERS AND SISTERS
AND STRONG SOLIDARITY WITH THAT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON SR 81. THANK YOU, SENATOR
BRADFORD. SENATOR WAHAB, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU. I
ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF SR 81
AAPI 2024 HERITAGE MONTH IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO THE
FABRIC OF OUR SOCIETY,
ESPECIALLY CALIFORNIA. AS
DIVERSE AS IT IS, I DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT AND ECHO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES BEING
ASIAN IS NOT A MONOLITH. THE
ASIAN COMMUNITY IS NOT A
MONOLITH. I REPRESENT THE
LARGEST ASIAN DISTRICT IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. NHÀ. AND I
WANT TO SAY THAT NOT ONLY ARE WE
MADE UP OF INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
BOTH REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRAT, NO
PARTY PREFERENCE AS WELL, BUT WE
HAVE THE VALUES AND IDEALS THAT
EVERY AMERICAN HAS. WE WANT TO
PROTECT OUR CHILDREN. WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE A GOOD
EDUCATION. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR FAMILIES ARE THRIVING,
THAT PEOPLE ARE SAFE, AND PEOPLE
ARE TREATED WITH FAIRNESS AND
DIGNITY. AND MORE AND MORE WE
SEE THIS ERODE IN OUR DAY TO DAY
TALKING, INTERACTIONS WITH
OTHERS. AND IT'S IMPORTANT AS
POLICY MAKERS THAT WE STAND UP
FOR EVERY SINGLE PERSON THAT
MAKES UP THIS COMMUNITY, AS WELL
AS THE ENTIRE AMERICAN COMMUNITY
. SO I'M VERY THANKFUL, AND I
WANT TO CONGRATULATE ALL OF OUR
HONOREES TODAY. IT WAS VERY
HARD, AT LEAST FOR ME, IN MY
DISTRICT, TO CHOOSE ONE
INDIVIDUAL THAT EXEMPLIFIES THE
IDEALS OF THIS COMMUNITY. SO I
THANK YOU. AND I ALSO WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
FOR SR 81. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR DURAZO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I WANT TO RISE AND
TALK ABOUT THE MANY AAPI
COMMUNITIES IN MY DISTRICT,
LITTLE TOKYO, CHINATOWN HISTORY,
FILIPINOTOWN, KOREATOWN AND THAI
TOWN. THESE ARE HISTORIC CENTERS
OF ARRIVALS OF THOSE VARIOUS
COMMUNITIES AND INDIVIDUALS WHO
OVER SEVERAL GENERATIONS HAVE
ARRIVED IN LOS ANGELES. THEY
REPRESENT THRIVING RESIDENTIAL
AND BUSINESS CENTERS, BUT THEY
ARE ALSO EMBEDDED IN THE LATINO
COMMUNITY SO THAT YOU GET THE
VIBRANCY AND THE DIVERSITY OF
VARIOUS COMMUNITIES ALL LIVING
IN TOGETHER. SO I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK THE MANY
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THESE VARIOUS
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SENATOR DURAZO. SENATOR
MCGUIRE, PLEASE LET ME GO TO
SENATOR WIENER FIRST, AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO YOU. SENATOR
MCGUIRE. SENATOR WIENER, THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SR 81. I'M PROUD TO
REPRESENT ONE OF THE LARGEST
AAPI COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE,
NEARLY 40% OF SENATE DISTRICT 11
I IDENTIFY IS A IS API. WE HAVE
A LARGE AND VIBRANT CHINESE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY, A LARGE AND
VIBRANT FILIPINO AMERICAN
COMMUNITY, AND OTHER GREAT
COMMUNITIES. AND I AM JUST SO
PROUD OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
NORTHERN SAN MATEO COUNTY FOR
BEING A PART OF OUR STATE THAT'S
SO DEEPLY EMBRACES THE AMAZING
DIVERSITY OF OUR COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
WIENER. SENATOR MCGUIRE, THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. I
RISE ALONGSIDE THE AAPI CAUCUS
IN SUPPORT OF ASIAN AMERICAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER HERITAGE MONTH
MEMBERS. I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO THE SENATOR. TO MY RIGHT, THE
SENATOR FROM IRVINE, WHO IS
CO-CHAIR OF THE AAPI CAUCUS FOR
BRINGING SR 81 TO THE FLOOR
TODAY, ALONG WITH ALL OF THE
CAUCUS MEMBERS. I THINK THAT WE
CAN ALL AGREE. YOU TAKE A LOOK
AT THE IMPACT THAT AAPI
RESIDENTS HAVE ON THIS STATE.
IT'S GREAT. THERE ARE 6 MILLION
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMUNITY WHO
PROUDLY CALL THE GOLDEN STATE
HOME, AND THE CULTURAL AND
ECONOMIC IMPACT THAT THIS
COMMUNITY HAS WEAVED, HAS WEAVED
INTO THE FABRIC OF THE STATE,
MEANS THAT THE GOLDEN STATE WILL
CONTINUE TO BE SUCCESSFUL FOR
DECADES TO COME. AND AS I
REFLECT BACK ON OUR STATE'S
HISTORY, I THINK THAT WE CAN
ALSO BE REMINDED THAT THE
PAINFUL MOMENTS OF THE PAST AND
THE INJUSTICES BROUGHT UPON THIS
COMMUNITY. WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT WE NEVER REPEAT THAT AGAIN.
I WANT TO SAY AGAIN, THANK YOU
TO EACH AND EVERY MEMBER OF THE
AAPI CAUCUS FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP
AND YOUR LEADERSHIP AND ADVOCACY
WILL CONTINUE TO EMPOWER AND
INSPIRE GENERATIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS TO COME. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON SR 81. THANK YOU, SENATOR
MCGUIRE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE? FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? SEEING NONE. SENATOR
MINH, YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I WANT TO THANK
THE PRESIDENT PRO TEMPORE FOR
HIS COMMENTS, AS WELL AS MY
COLLEAGUES, INCLUDING FROM THE
SENATOR, FROM HUNTINGTON BEACH,
THE SENATOR FROM HAYWARD, OUR
FELLOW AAPI IN THE SENATE WOULD
JUST POINT OUT ONE FINAL THING
HERE. ASIAN AMERICANS AND
PACIFIC ISLANDERS COME FROM
COUNTRIES THAT REPRESENT ROUGHLY
60% OF THE WORLD'S POPULATION.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THEIR ROLE
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES, WE
HAVE AN INCREDIBLE, DIVERSE
TAPESTRY OF EXPERIENCES AND
HERITAGES TO DRAW FROM. AND WHAT
THIS IS AS MUCH AS THIS IS A
CELEBRATION OF ASIAN AMERICANS
AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS, THIS
MONTH IS ALSO CELEBRATION OF
DIVERSITY, AND I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THE IMPORTANCE OF THAT
AT A TIME WHEN DIVERSITY IS
BEING QUESTIONED, WHEN INCLUSION
IS BEING QUESTIONED AS A CORE
VALUE OF THE UNITED STATES, THIS
IS A CELEBRATION OF DIVERSITY.
SO WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON SR 81. ALL
DEBATE HAVING CEASED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALVARADO GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALY. AYE. DODD. AYE
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE. OCHOA.
BOGH AYE. PADILLA. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
CIERTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE UMMER. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN.
AYE ATKINS. GONZALEZ. MENGIBAR
PADILLA. ON A VOTE OF 36 TO 0,
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR. WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO SENATOR MIN AT THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK. SENATOR
MIN, THANK YOU, MISTER
PRESIDENT. AS PART OF THE
CELEBRATION OF AAPI HERITAGE
MONTH, THE ASIAN AMERICAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS RECOGNIZES AND HONORS
DISTINGUISHED AAPI LEADERS FROM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THIS YEAR,
WE'RE PROUD TO RECOGNIZE 15
HONOREES WHO HAVE DEMONSTRATED
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO STEP UP,
SPEAK OUT, AND LEAD OUR
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU TO ALL OF
OUR HONOREES FOR UPLIFTING AAPI
VOICES AND INSISTING THAT OUR
COMMUNITY BE VISIBLE AND HEARD.
WE'RE PROUD TO BE ASIAN
AMERICANS AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS,
AND WE ARE INCREDIBLY PROUD TO
CELEBRATE AAPI HERITAGE MONTH
WITH YOU. WITH THAT, OUR FIRST
HONOREE IS JASON CHAN. JASON
SERVES AS CHIEF OF STAFF TO KEN
MCNEELY, AT-ATS PRESIDENT OF THE
WEST REGION, AS WELL AS AS THE
DIRECTOR OF EXTERNAL AFFAIRS,
WHERE HE LEADS AT-ATS NATIONAL,
ASIAN AMERICAN NATIVE HAWAIIAN
AND PACIFIC ISLANDER ENGAGEMENT.
PRIOR TO JOINING AT&T, JASON
HELD MULTIPLE GOVERNMENT
APPOINTMENTS WITH THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO,
INCLUDING AS APPOINTMENTS
SECRETARY FOR THEN MAYOR GAVIN
NEWSOM, AND SERVED AS THE
POLITICAL DIRECTOR FOR THE ED
LEE FOR MAYOR CAMPAIGN. JASON
CURRENTLY SERVES ON THE BOARD OF
THE NATIONAL ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND
ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND THE ASIAN
PACIFIC AMERICAN INSTITUTE FOR
CONGRESSIONAL STUDIES.
CONGRATULATIONS, JASON.
AND MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
INDIVIDUAL PICTURES AS WE GO
THROUGH THE HONOREES. AND THEN
WE'LL DO A GROUP PICTURE AT THE
END. THANKS, JASON. OUR NEXT
HONOREE IS CHUN YING CHEN. AS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC COMMUNITY FUND, CHUN
HIÆN PROVIDES EXECUTIVE
LEADERSHIP AND DIRECTS
OPERATIONS AND GRANT MAKING FOR
THE ORGANIZATION. UNDER HER
LEADERSHIP, APF HAS GROWN FROM
12 ASIAN AMERICAN NONPROFITS. IN
1990 TO OVER 80 AAPI NONPROFITS
IN 2024. TOGETHER, APF AND ITS
NETWORK PROVIDE PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES IN 43 AAPI LANGUAGES,
COVERING OVER 1.25 MILLION
PEOPLE. IN HER ROLE AS THE
GATEWAY AND RESOURCES CONSULTANT
FOR ÁP PHILANTHROPY, CHUN YEN
HAS WORKED CLOSELY WITH
INDIVIDUALS, FAMILIES AND
ENTREPRENEURS TO ESTABLISH DONOR
ADVISED, FUND GIVING CIRCLE AND
CUSTOMIZED SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM
TO CREATE A PHILANTHROPIC LEGACY
AND CENTRALIZED AAPI GIVING
POWER. CONGRATULATIONS, CHUN YAN
.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. APPRECIATE IT
. OKAY. NEXT UP WE HAVE DOCTOR
KENNETH FONG, WHO IS A CIVIC
LEADER, PHILANTHROPIST,
BIOMEDICAL ENTREPRENEUR AND
CULTIVATOR. HE SERVED AS A
TRUSTEE IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM FOR SEVEN
YEARS AND WITNESSED THE
INSTALLATION OF THREE NEW ASIAN
AMERICAN PRESIDENTS AT BAY AREA
CSU CAMPUSES. HE'S ALSO VERY
GENEROUS WITH SCHOLARSHIPS,
INCLUDING ENDOWING THE ANNUAL
TRUSTEE FONG SCHOLARSHIP AND THE
ANNUAL KENNETH S FONG
TRANSLATIONAL RESEARCH AWARD FOR
FACULTY AND STUDENTS AT SAN
FRANCISCO STATE UNIVERSITY. HIS
CONTRIBUTIONS HAVE WARRANTED HIM
EARNING A PLACE IN THE ALUMNI
HALL OF FAME IN 1998, AND ALUMNI
OF THE YEAR IN 2006 FROM SAN
FRANCISCO STATE DOCTOR FONG
FOUNDED HIS FIRST BIOTECH
COMPANY, CLEANTECH CLEANTECH, IN
1984 AND GREW IT TO 400
EMPLOYEES, BEING THE LARGEST OF
HIS KIND BY AN ASIAN AMERICAN AT
THE TIME. HE THEN BECAME AN
INCUBATOR, SEEDING AND
CULTIVATING OVER 15 BIOTECH
COMPANIES OVER THE YEARS.
CONGRATULATIONS, KENNETH
.
THANK YOU. OKAY, NEXT UP, I
WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME AUDRA
IBARRA. GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN
APPOINTED JUDGE IBARRA TO THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY SUPERIOR
COURT IN DECEMBER 2018. SHE'S
THE FIRST FILIPINO AMERICAN
JUDGE IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND
FEMALE TRIAL JUDGE IN THE BAY
AREA. CHIEF JUSTICE TANI
CANTIL-SAKAUYE APPOINTED JUDGE
IBARRA AS A PRO TEM JUSTICE ON
THE SECOND DISTRICT COURT OF
APPEAL FROM JUNE 2021 TO JANUARY
2022. JUDGE IBARRA IS ALSO A
FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC
AMERICAN JUDGES ASSOCIATION AND
A FORMER VOTING MEMBER OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. SHE CURRENTLY
SERVES ON THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
CRIMINAL LAW ADVISORY COMMITTEE,
AND IS A FOUNDING MEMBER AND
TREASURER OF THE CALIFORNIA
WOMEN JUDGES. CONGRATULATIONS
JUDGE. CONGRATULATIONS. OH MY
TOP. OKAY, THERE WE GO. THANK
YOU. ADMINISTRATION. THANK YOU.
JUDGE THANK YOU. OH, WONDERFUL.
YEAH. THAT'S RIGHT. OUR NEXT
HONOREE IS FENG LÀ. AND THIS IS
YOU RIGHT HERE. FENG FENG IS AN
ASSESSOR FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY.
AND CHAMPIONS ASIAN-AMERICAN
EMPOWERMENT CAUSES. HIS WORK HAS
MOTIVATED OTHERS TO EMBRACE HIS
IDEAS. FENG BUILT A REPUTATION
FOR DEVELOPING POLITICAL
ALLIANCES, BUILDING POLITICAL
STRATEGIES, INCUBATING COMMUNITY
RELATIONSHIPS, AND STRENGTHENING
COMMUNITY PROGRAMS THROUGH
VARIOUS COMMUNITIES AND
POLITICAL ACTIVITIES. FENG HAS
ESTABLISHED STRONG RELATIONSHIPS
WITH FEDERAL, STATE, AND LOCAL
LEADERS THROUGHOUT THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA.
CONGRATULATIONS. AND HE'S A VERY
GOOD DANCER. GOTTA HAVE FUN.
COME ON, LET'S TAKE A PHOTO.
CONGRATULATIONS. WAS REALLY
STRONG. IT ONLY HAPPENS ONCE IN
YOUR LIFE. I'LL HAVE TO DO IT.
COME ON. STEVE, THANKS. I WILL
NOW TURN TO MY COLLEAGUE,
SENATOR WAHAB TO INTRODUCE THE
NEXT HONOREE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. WE JUST HONORED FENG LÀ,
WHO'S OUR COUNTY ASSESSOR IN MY
DISTRICT AS WELL. AND NOW WE
HAVE DOCTOR DANVY. LEE IS OUR
NEXT HONOREE. DOCTOR LEE IS AN
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF POLITICAL SCIENCE
AT CSU EAST BAY. A CHILD OF
REFUGEES, DOCTOR LEE WAS BORN
AND RAISED IN LITTLE SAIGON,
ORANGE COUNTY, CALIFORNIA. BUT
SHE IS A TRUE EAST BAYER. WE FOR
SHE WAS INSPIRED BY THE
POLITICAL ACTIVISM, ACTIVITY AND
ACTIVISM OF THE VIETNAMESE
AMERICANS, A FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE GRADUATE, SHE EARNED HER
DOCTORATE AT UC IRVINE AND
CENTERS HER WORK AROUND
COMMUNITY INCLUSION AND
EMPOWERMENT. HER RESEARCH
EXAMINES MOBILIZING COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR TOWARDS POLITICAL
INCORPORATION AND APPEARS IN
SEVERAL ACADEMIC JOURNALS. SHE
WAS ONE OF THE FIRST PROFESSORS
TO STAND UP AGAINST A VERY
DIFFICULT TIME OF, YOU KNOW,
JUST A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO WITH
ANTI-ASIAN POLICIES, ANTI-MUSLIM
POLICIES, AND SHE ENSURED THAT
STUDENTS COULD HEAR THEIR OWN
VOICE AND RAISE IT TO PEOPLE IN
POWER IN THE COMMUNITY. DOCTOR
LEE HAS VOLUNTEERED WITH
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING AAPI
WOMEN LEAD, INITIATE JUSTICE,
AND THE ELLA BAKER CENTER TO
UPLIFT COMMUNITIES. DOCTOR LEE'S
COMMITMENT TO HER COMMUNITY AND
HER STUDENTS SETS A STANDARD FOR
OTHERS TO FOLLOW.
CONGRATULATIONS, DOCTOR LEE
.
CONGRATULATIONS. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. NEXT UP, WE HAVE PATRICK
LEE. PATRICK IS AN ENTREPRENEUR
BEST KNOWN FOR BEING A
CO-FOUNDER AND THE FOUNDING CEO
OF A WEBSITE YOU MAY HAVE HEARD
OF ROTTEN TOMATOES, A LEADING
ENTERTAINMENT WEBSITE FOCUSED ON
MOVIE REVIEWS AND NEWS, HE'S THE
CO-FOUNDER AND CEO AS WELL OF
FAN VERSE, A CURATED COMMUNITY
OF THE BEST BUILDERS, CREATORS,
AND TALENTED ALL AROUND COMIC
CON FANDOM. PRIOR TO THAT, HE
WAS CO-FOUNDER AND MANAGING
PARTNER OF PCO INVESTMENTS, A
SYNDICATE OF NOTABLE INVESTORS
INVESTING IN THE NEXT GENERATION
OF FOUNDERS AT THE INTERSECTION
OF TECH AND ENTERTAINMENT. HE'S
AN ACTIVE ADVISOR TO A NUMBER OF
STARTUPS, AND ALSO MENTORED AND
OR SUPPORTED PROGRAMS AT 500
STARTUPS SAU, SV, BERKELEY,
SKYDECK, BLUE STARTUPS, FOUNDER
INSTITUTE, AND MORE. LET'S GIVE
A BIG HAND A LOT OF TOMATOES FOR
PATRICK. CONGRATULATIONS.
OKAY YOU'LL GET ANOTHER ONE
LATER. OUR NEXT HONOREE IS
FRANCIS LUJAN. FRAN IS MY
HONOREE AND IS THE FIRST
INDIGENOUS PERSON OF THE MARIANA
ISLANDS FROM THE ISLAND OF GUAM
TO HOLD THE POSITION OF MUSEUM
DIRECTOR IN THE CONTINENTAL
UNITED STATES. SHE'S THE
GUARDIAN OF THE PACIFIC ISLANDS.
BELOVED ANCESTRAL PIECES AT
CALIFORNIA'S PACIFIC ISLAND
ETHNIC ART MUSEUM. HER PRACTICE
OF CARE IS ROOTED IN RE
INDIGENIZATION, RADICAL JOY, AND
INTERGENERATIONAL CURATION.
THAT'S A COOL PHRASE. SHE HOLDS
SPACE TO ILLUMINATE THE
MULTIPLICITIES OF PACIFIC
ISLANDER ARTISTS AND CULTURAL
PRACTITIONERS. PRACTITIONERS
PRESENCE AND PRACTICES IN ROOTS
AND IN ROOTS. AS A RECIPIENT OF
THE ERNEST M PAWN AWARD FROM THE
ASSOCIATION OF ETHNIC STUDIES,
FRAN IS RECOGNIZED AS AN ASIAN
AMERICAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
WHO'S DEDICATED TO HUMAN RIGHTS
AND EQUAL JUSTICE AMONG NATIVE
HAWAIIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITIES. SHE'S LOVINGLY
REFERRED TO AS AUNTIE FRAN, AND
WE TALK A LOT IN THE AANHPI
COMMUNITIES ABOUT OUR COHESION.
BUT REALLY, TOO OFTEN IT'S ABOUT
THE AA AND NOT ENOUGH ABOUT THE
NH OR PI. AND SO IT REALLY IS, I
THINK, AN HONOR TO BE ABLE TO
INTRODUCE AUNTIE FRAN HERE.
CONGRATULATIONS, FRAN.
OUR NEXT, OUR NEXT HONOREE MAY
BE FAMILIAR TO MANY OF THE BAY
AREA FOLKS HERE. RAJ MATHAI IS A
12 TIME EMMY AWARD WINNER AND
THE WEEKNIGHT NEWS ANCHOR FOR
NBC BAY AREA, ANCHORING THE
NIGHTLY 5:30 P.M, 6 P.M, 7 P.M.
AND 11 P.M. NEWS. THAT'S QUITE A
LOT, ADDITIONALLY, HE WAS AMONG
THE BAY AREA'S MOST WELL KNOWN
JOURNALISTS. IN 1995, RAJ BECAME
THE COUNTRY'S FIRST INDIAN
SPORTSCASTER. PRIOR TO HIS
CAREER IN TELEVISION, HE SERVED
AS A PUBLIC RELATIONS ASSISTANT
FOR THE SAN DIEGO CHARGERS FOR
FIVE SEASONS. HE AND HIS FAMILY
CONTRIBUTE TO VARIOUS BAY AREA
CHARITIES, AND RAJ CURRENTLY
SERVES ON THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS
FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO SYMPHONY
AND THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR
THE ASIAN PACIFIC FUND.
CONGRATULATIONS, RAJ. THANK YOU
.
THERE YOU GO. THERE YOU GO. ALL
RIGHT, ALL RIGHT. THE NEXT
HONOREE IS ALSO FAMILIAR TO MANY
OF US HERE BECAUSE WE'VE HAD THE
PLEASURE OF DINING AT HIS
RESTAURANT. PROBABLY THE HARDEST
RESERVATION TO GET IN TOWN.
BILLY INGO, CHEF BILLY IS THE
FOUNDER, CHEF AND PARTNER OF
CRU. CONTEMPORARY JAPANESE
CUISINE. FISH FACE POKE BAR,
HEALTHY HOUND'S KITCHEN AND KHÎI
KHÓ RAMEN AND BAR IN SACRAMENTO.
BILLY WAS BORN IN A REFUGEE CAMP
IN HONG KONG AND MOVED TO
SACRAMENTO WHEN HE WAS EIGHT
MONTHS OLD. SINCE THEN, HE'S
OBVIOUSLY MADE TREMENDOUS
STRIDES IN THE WORLD OF FOOD AND
WINE. HE'S A FEATURED CHEF AT
PEBBLE BEACH FOOD AND WINE IN
LOS ANGELES, FOOD AND WINE, AND
IN ADDITION, HE'S MADE SEVERAL
TELEVISION APPEARANCES ON
POPULAR CULINARY SHOWS,
INCLUDING GLUTTON FOR PUNISHMENT
, MAN, FIRE FOOD, CUTTHROAT
KITCHEN, AND CHOPPED. THIS YEAR,
BILLY WAS NAMED A FINALIST FOR
THE PRESTIGIOUS JAMES BEARD
AWARDS CATEGORY, BEST CHEF
KITCHEN, BEST CHEF CALIFORNIA,
WITH THE RESULTS, I GUESS, BEING
ANNOUNCED ON JUNE 10TH.
CONGRATULATIONS, BILLY. THANK
YOU
.
NEXT UP WE HAVE, TERESITA DE
SANTIAGO, BORN AND RAISED IN THE
PHILIPPINES. TESS MIGRATED TO
THE US IN 1965 AT THE AGE OF 14.
SHE'S THE FIRST FEMALE MAYOR IN
THE HISTORY OF DELANO, AND THE
FIRST FEMALE MAYOR OF FILIPINO
ANCESTRY IN THE UNITED STATES.
SHE HAS SERVED AS MAYOR FOR TWO
YEARS, AND ALSO SERVED AS CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER FOR THE CITY OF
DELANO FOR SIX YEARS. FOR HER
SERVICE AND LEADERSHIP ROLES IN
VARIOUS BOARDS AND
ORGANIZATIONS, SHE WAS NAMED A
RECIPIENT OF THE 1994
LEGISLATIVE WOMAN OF THE YEAR
AWARD. CONGRATULATIONS, TERESITA
.
OUR NEXT HONOREE IS GREG SARRIS.
GREG RECEIVED HIS PH.D. IN
MODERN THOUGHT AND LITERATURE
FROM STANFORD UNIVERSITY, WHERE
HE WAS AWARDED THE WALTER GORE
AWARD FOR EXCELLENCE IN
TEACHING. HE IS NOW SERVING HIS
16TH CONSECUTIVE ELECTED TERM AS
CHAIRMAN OF THE FEDERATED
INDIANS OF GRATON RANCHERIA. IN
ADDITION TO SERVING AS CHAIRMAN
OF HIS TRIBE, HE SERVES AS
PRESIDENT OF THE TRIBE'S
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT BOARD, AND
IN JUNE 2023, HE WAS APPOINTED
BY GOVERNOR NEWSOM TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S BOARD
OF REGENTS. GREG HAS PUBLISHED
SEVERAL BOOKS, INCLUDING GRAND
AVENUE, AN AWARD WINNING
COLLECTION OF SHORT STORIES
WHICH HE ADAPTED FOR AN HBO MINI
SERIES AND CO-EXECUTIVE PRODUCED
WITH ROBERT REDFORD. THIS PAST
APRIL, HE RELEASED HIS NEWEST
PUBLICATION, THE FORGETTERS,
ACCEPTING ON HIS BEHALF. TODAY
IS PHIL PANGELINAN.
CONGRATULATIONS, GREG, AND THANK
YOU, PHIL
.
OKAY, WE'RE NEARING THE END
HERE, GUYS, I PROMISE, OUR NEXT
HONOREE IS KIM TAVAGLIONE. KIM
WAS BORN IN SEOUL, SOUTH KOREA,
IN Ã TO A US MILITARY MAN AND A
SOUTH KOREAN WOMAN. AS A FIRST
GENERATION STUDENT, KIM ATTENDED
CITY COLLEGE OF SAN FRANCISCO
AND LATER GRADUATED FROM SAN
FRANCISCO STATE UNIVERSITY. KIM
BECAME INVOLVED IN THE LABOR
MOVEMENT IN 2002, WHEN SHE
JOINED THE STAFF OF SEIU 250 AS
A UNION REPRESENTATIVE. SHE
MOVED ON TO LATER BECOME THE
COMMUNITY AND POLITICAL DIRECTOR
AT NYU. DURING THIS TIME, KIM
SERVED AS AN EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE
MEMBER OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
LABOR COUNCIL FOR NEARLY A
DECADE. SHE JOINED THE COUNCIL
AS CAMPAIGN DIRECTOR IN
SEPTEMBER OF 2018, AND IN 2020
ASSUMED THE ROLE OF EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR, BECOMING THE FIRST
WOMAN TO LEAD THE SAN FRANCISCO
LABOR COUNCIL. CONGRATULATIONS
TO KIM IN ACCEPTING THE AWARD ON
HER BEHALF. IS SHUBHANGI DOMOKOS
.
OKAY. THE NEXT HONOREE IS GOLD
HOUSE. THAT'S NOT THE NAME OF A
PERSON, BUT RATHER A LEADING
CULTURAL ECOSYSTEM. AIM TO
UNITE, INVEST IN, AND CHAMPION
ASIAN PACIFIC CREATORS AND
COMPANIES TO POWER TOMORROW FOR
ALL THEIR INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS
AND PLATFORMS, INCLUDE
MEMBERSHIP SYSTEMS AND EVENTS TO
FORTIFY RELATIONSHIPS AMONG THE
ASIAN AMERICAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITY, AS WELL AS
WITH OTHER MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES. FIRST OF ITS KIND,
INVESTMENT VEHICLES AND
ACCELERATORS ARE CREATED BY THEM
TO PROPEL THE NEXT GENERATION OF
TOP AAPI FOUNDERS, CREATIVES AND
LEADERS, AS WELL AS INDUSTRY
LEADING RESEARCH, CONSULTING,
AND MARKETING TO PROMOTE
AUTHENTIC AND AFFIRMING
PORTRAYALS. CONGRATULATIONS TO
GOLD HOUSE HERE TO ACCEPT THE
HONOR ON THEIR BEHALF IS GOLD
HOUSE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR, COO,
AND CO-FOUNDER JEREMY TRAN.
CONGRATULATIONS TO ALL THE
HONOREES. WE WANT TO INVITE ALL
THE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE TO
JOIN IN A PHOTOGRAPH AT THE
BACK. WE'LL TAKE A PAUSE. OH,
THERE'S ONE MORE, FINALLY, WE
HAVE ALAN NISHIO. THE LATE ALAN
NISHIO, ALAN WAS A DEDICATED AND
RESPECTED LEADER IN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITY WHO HAD SPENT
MORE THAN FIVE DECADES WORKING
WITH MULTIPLE GENERATIONS IN
SOCIAL AND CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
PROGRAMS. HE SERVED AS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS FOR THE LITTLE TOKYO
SERVICE CENTER, THE LEADING ÁP
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION IN THE REGION FOR
OVER 12 YEARS, AND HE ALSO
SERVED AS AN LZC BOARD MEMBER
FOR OVER 36 YEARS. IN
RECOGNITION OF HIS WORK, ALAN
WAS AWARDED THE ORDER OF THE
RISING SUN OR KUNSHO AWARD FROM
THE JAPANESE GOVERNMENT IN
RECOGNITION OF HIS WORK IN THE
JAPANESE-AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND
EFFORTS TO STRENGTHEN
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN JAPAN AND
THE UNITED STATES.
CONGRATULATIONS TO ALAN AND HIS
FAMILY. OKAY, I THINK THAT
CONCLUDES THAT PART OF THE
CEREMONY. WE WANT TO INVITE ALL
THE AAPI CAUCUS MEMBERS TO FIRST
JOIN A PICTURE WITH THE
HONOREES, AND THEN WE'LL INVITE
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE TO ALSO
PARTICIPATE IF THEY WOULD LIKE
.
OKAY, SO LET'S INVITE. NOW, IF
THE HONOREES CAN REMAIN THERE,
THEY INVITE MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE TO ALSO JOIN. WE'LL TAKE
A SHORT PAUSE
.
IS MEMBERS. WE ARE GOING TO
INVITE SENATOR MINH FOR SOME
CLOSING COMMENTS. MEMBERS, LET'S
GIVE SENATOR MINH YOUR ATTENTION
, PLEASE. SENATOR MINH, THANK
YOU. IN HONOR OF AAPI HERITAGE
MONTH, WE'VE GIVEN YOU SOME
SMALL GIFTS. YOU HAVE MEMENTOS
ON YOUR DESK IN SUPPORT OF OUR
AAPI MUSEUMS. WE HAVE FROM THE
ASIAN ART MUSEUM, A CERAMIC
DRAGON DESIGN BALL WITH BUILT IN
CHOPSTICKS. COOL STUFF,
COMPLEMENTING TODAY'S FLOOR
CEREMONY, WE ALSO WANT TO CALL
IT TO YOUR ATTENTION, THE
BANNERS HANGING FROM THE SECOND
FLOOR OF THE ROTUNDA, TO FURTHER
AMPLIFY THE ACHIEVEMENTS OF OUR
HONOREES, THESE BANNERS WILL BE
DISPLAYED FOR THE ENTIRE WEEK
FOR MEMBERS, STAFF, AND VISITORS
TO SEE. FINALLY, TONIGHT AT 8
P.M, THE DOME OF THE CAPITOL
WILL BE LIT. GOLD IN RECOGNITION
OF ASIAN-AMERICAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER HERITAGE MONTH,
HONORING THE ACHIEVEMENTS OF OUR
HONOREES AND ALL OF THE APIS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THANK YOU
ALL FOR CELEBRATING AAPI
HERITAGE MONTH AND OUR 2024
HONOREES. THANK YOU, SENATOR
MINH. THANK YOU TO YOUR CAUCUS
MEMBERS AS WELL FOR ORGANIZING
THE WONDERFUL CEREMONY ON OUR
FLOOR TODAY. MEMBERS, WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE WITH
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. WE HAVE
A PRESENTATION BY SENATOR ALLEN
AND SENATOR DURAZO. WE'RE GOING
TO FIRST BEGIN WITH SENATOR
ALLEN AT THE MAJORITY LEADER'S
DESK. PLEASE GIVE HIM YOUR
ATTENTION. MEMBERS WELL, THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. IT'S
A REAL HONOR THIS AFTERNOON TO
WELCOME TO OUR SENATE CHAMBER AN
ICONIC CALIFORNIAN, THE AWARD
WINNING ACTOR, PRODUCER,
DIRECTOR AND DEDICATED
HUMANITARIAN, EDWARD JAMES
OLMOS, A NATIVE SON OF THE
GOLDEN STATE, MR. OLMOS WAS BORN
IN 1947 TO MEXICAN IMMIGRANT
PARENTS, PEDRO OLMOS AND ELEANOR
WISSER, AND HE WAS RAISED IN
EAST LA IN BOYLE HEIGHTS.
FOLLOWING HIS CHILDHOOD IN
MONTEBELLO, HE WENT ON TO EARN A
DEGREE IN SOCIOLOGY AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE FROM EAST L.A. COLLEGE
IN 1966, WHICH WAS RIGHT AROUND
THE TIME THAT HE BEGAN TO
DEVELOP AN INTEREST IN ACTING IN
THEATER AND FILM. AFTER MANY
NUMEROUS SMALLER STAGE
APPEARANCES, MR. OLMOS RECEIVED
HIS BIG BREAK WHEN HE WAS CAST
AS EL PACHUCO IN LUIS VALDEZ'S
GREAT, GROUNDBREAKING PLAY ZOOT
SUIT, WHICH PREMIERED IN THE
MARK TAPER FORUM IN LA IN 1978.
ORIGINALLY SCHEDULED FOR JUST
TEN PERFORMANCES, THE PRODUCTION
DREW CROWDS FOR A YEAR AND A
HALF IN DOWNTOWN BEFORE HEADING
EAST AS THE VERY FIRST CHICANO
PLAY ON BROADWAY, WHERE ALMOST
RECEIVED A TONY NOMINATION. MR.
OLMOS WAS WELL ON HIS WAY TO
BECOMING THE CULTURAL ICON THAT
HE IS TODAY, AND CONTINUED ON TO
COMPLEMENT HIS THEATER ACCOLADES
WITH SUCCESS IN TELEVISION AND
FILM. FROM HIS ICONIC ROLE, OF
COURSE, IN STAND AND DELIVER,
PORTRAYING HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER
JAIME ESCALANTE, HIS EMMY
WINNING ROLE IN THE TV SERIES
MIAMI VICE, HIS POPULAR ROLE
STARRING AS WILLIAM ADAMA IN
BATTLESTAR GALACTICA, TO HIS
MOST MORE RECENT TURN, AS IN
MAYANS MC AS FELIPE REYES. EACH
ROLE TAKEN ON BY MR. OLMOS HAS
ELEVATED BY THE TALENT, NUANCE
AND EMOTIONAL TRUTH THAT HE
BRINGS. AND I JUST FOUND OUT
TODAY THAT THAT STAND AND
DELIVER IS APPARENTLY THE MOST
THE MOST SCREENED FILM IN IN
AMERICAN HISTORY WITHIN THE
UNITED STATES BECAUSE IT'S BEEN
SCREENED SO MANY TIMES WITHIN
CLASSROOMS, WHICH IS A PRETTY
EXTRAORDINARY THING GIVEN MORE
THAN GONE WITH THE WIND, MORE
THAN STAR WARS IS. IT'S SHOWN IN
EVERY SINGLE CLASS, SOMETIMES
SEVERAL TIMES. I THINK PARTLY
THE TEACHERS ARE GIVING
THEMSELVES INSPIRATION, BUT, YOU
KNOW, WE'VE ALL SEEN IT AND
WE'VE ALL BEEN SO INSPIRED BY
THAT WONDERFUL FILM. ALONGSIDE,
THOUGH HIS VENERABLE FIVE DECADE
CAREER AS A DECORATED ACTOR, MR.
OLMOS IS JUST AS WELL KNOWN FOR
HIS DEEP COMMITMENT TO
HUMANITARIAN EFFORTS AND HIS
YEARS OF WORK FOSTERING
OPPORTUNITIES AND CULTURAL
REPRESENTATION BOTH ON AND OFF
SCREEN THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER,
MR. OLMOS HAS ALWAYS CHOSEN TO
LEVERAGE HIS TALENT, HIS
EXPERIENCE AND HIS PERSONAL
SUCCESS TO BENEFIT HIS COMMUNITY
AND LIFT UP THE LIVES OF THOSE
AROUND HIM. HIS HEART FOR HIS
HOMETOWN COMMUNITY WAS PUT ON
DISPLAY IN THE DAYS FOLLOWING
THE RIOTS. THE UPRISINGS OF
1992, IN LOS ANGELES WHEN MR.
OLMOS SPARKED A SPONTANEOUS
MOVEMENT OF UNITY AND
RESTORATION, ALL ALL WITH JUST A
BROOM. WHEN HE REALIZED THAT HE
COULDN'T BREAK THROUGH TO THE
PEOPLE IN THE STREETS THROUGH TV
OR RADIO, HE TOOK IT UPON
HIMSELF TO START CLEANING UP THE
CITY THAT HE LOVED. AND WHILE HE
STARTED SWEEPING WITH ONLY A FEW
FRIENDS, THEY WERE THEN JOINED
BY NEIGHBORS AND FELLOW
ANGELENOS UNTIL THERE WERE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN THE
STREETS WORKING TO PUT THEIR
CITY BACK TOGETHER AGAIN. IN
1998. SEVERAL YEARS LATER,
SEEING A LACK OF REPRESENTATION
IN THE MEDIA FROM LATINO VOICES
AND PERSPECTIVES, MR. OLMOS
FOUNDED THE NONPROFIT LATINO
PUBLIC BROADCASTING. THEY NOW
PLAY A VITAL ROLE IN AMPLIFYING
LATINO VOICES AND ISSUES THROUGH
PROGRAMS AND FINANCIAL SUPPORT
OF MEDIA PROJECTS, NURTURING
THEM FROM DEVELOPMENT ALL THE
WAY THROUGH DISTRIBUTION. AND
BECAUSE ONE MAJOR NONPROFIT
ISN'T ENOUGH ON HIS PLATE, HE
ALSO ESTABLISHED THE LATINO FILM
INSTITUTE, LFA, WITH ITS
FLAGSHIP EVENT THAT SO MANY OF
YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR WITH THE LOS
ANGELES LATINO INTERNATIONAL
FILM FESTIVAL, WHICH PROVIDES A
PIPELINE, A PLATFORM, AND A
LAUNCHING PAD FOR DIVERSE LATINO
STORYTELLING. AS EVERYONE
DESERVES TO HAVE THEIR STORIES
TOLD. NOW, THESE PROGRAMS
WOULDN'T BE POSSIBLE TODAY. IT
WOULDN'T BE POSSIBLE WITHOUT THE
WONDERFUL FOLKS LEADING THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS DAY TO DAY, MANY
OF WHOM WERE ACTUALLY HERE
JOINING US IN THE IN THE
GALLERY. THEY'RE ALL FILMING, OF
COURSE, BECAUSE THEY'RE FILM
PEOPLE, THANKS. VERY SPECIAL
THANKS TO BONNIE GARCIA, AXEL
CABALLERO, JAIME RODRIGUEZ,
LORRAINE VALVERDE, EDDIE LARIOS,
MY GOOD FRIEND. WE USED TO WORK
TOGETHER AT ZEV YAROSLAVSKY
OFFICE A LONG TIME AGO. THE
COUNTLESS OTHERS INVOLVED, SINCE
MY FIRST DAYS IN THE SENATE, I,
ALONG WITH MANY OF YOU, I'VE.
I'VE SERVED ON THE JOINT
COMMITTEE OF THE ARTS, AND WE'VE
HAD HEARINGS TO ADDRESS ARTS
EDUCATION ISSUES. AND WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE'VE BEEN
FAILING TO DELIVER ARTS
EDUCATION EQUITABLY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE, UNDERSTANDING THAT
EXPOSURE TO THE ARTS HAS SUCH A
VITAL IMPACT ON STUDENTS
DEVELOPMENT AND EDUCATIONAL
SUCCESS. IN FACT, WE KNOW THAT A
STRONG ARTS EDUCATION IS
OFTENTIMES THE MOST IMPORTANT
FACTOR IN DETERMINING WHETHER A
STUDENT WILL DROP OUT OR NOT,
BECAUSE IT'S A WAY TO CONNECT TO
A STUDENT WHO MIGHT BE
DISCONNECTED FROM THE
TRADITIONAL CURRICULUM. BUT. AND
IT TELLS THAT KID, HEY, I CAN BE
GOOD AT SCHOOL. I AM CONNECTING
TO THE CURRICULUM, AND IT'S SO
IT'S SO IT'S SO IMPORTANT. AND
SO IT'S ONE OF THE MANY REASONS
WHY I WANTED TO HONOR MR. OLMOS
HERE TODAY. WITH, WITH WITH YOU,
YOU RECENTLY HAD THE PLEASURE OF
SPENDING A DAY WITH HIM. WE
ATTENDED AN EDUCATION EVENT
TOGETHER, AND SAU. I GOT TO SEE
FIRSTHAND HIS DEVOTION TO
CREATING POSITIVE PATHS FOR
EVERY STUDENT. THE LFI, AMONG
THE MANY PROGRAMS THAT IT THAT
IT CONDUCTS, DEVOTED TO
EDUCATIONAL ENRICHMENT AND
ADVANCEMENT, INNOVATION AND
EMPOWERMENT OF EMERGING TALENT.
THE PROGRAM, I THINK THAT
THEY'RE MOST PROUD OF. AND I
THINK THEY'LL TELL YOU THE SAME
IF YOU IF YOU TALK TO THEM, IS
THIS THIS IS THE YOUTH CINEMA
PROJECT, WHICH REALLY FOCUSES
ON, ON ON STUDENT TRAJECTORIES.
IT'S AN ARTS EDUCATION AND
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY WORKFORCE
PIPELINE. IT'S MAKING A TANGIBLE
DIFFERENCE ON CAMPUSES AND IN
THE LIVES OF CREATIVE YOUNG
PEOPLE BY SPARKING HOPES, DREAMS
AND REAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUTH
IN TITLE ONE SCHOOLS, ALL UP AND
DOWN THE STATE. AND IT BRINGS
PRACTITIONERS FROM HOLLYWOOD AND
FILMMAKING RIGHT INTO OUR
SCHOOLS TO WORK WITH THE
STUDENTS AND
GET THEM EXCITED AND ACTUALLY
TEACH THEM THE SKILLS IS SO
SUCCESSFUL. CAREER PATHS AND THE
LEADERS FROM THAT, FROM THE
PROGRAM, THAT FROM THE YOUTH
CINEMA PROJECT HAVE PARTICIPATED
IN ONE OF OUR RECENT ARTS
HEARINGS TO SHARE THE BENEFITS
THAT ADMINISTRATORS, TEACHERS
AND STUDENTS ARE REALIZING WHEN
THEY BRING THEIR PROGRAM ONTO
CAMPUS. AND WE'RE VERY
PRIVILEGED TODAY TO HAVE SOME OF
THOSE TEACHERS AND
SUPERINTENDENTS IN ATTENDANCE
TODAY, DOCTOR RAUL MALDONADO,
SANDY MCCULLOCH AND DOCTOR
ALFONSO JIMENEZ. AND RIGHT HERE
ON THE FLOOR, AN INCREDIBLE
TEACHER, REBECCA COAHUILA, WHO
IS HERE, FROM JEFFERSON UNIFIED.
AND WE JUST WANTED TO HONOR HER
BY BY BRINGING HER TO THE FLOOR
TODAY. SO THIS IS A SPECIAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO PRESENT A
SENATE RESOLUTION TO SOMEONE WHO
HAS MADE SUCH A DIFFERENCE IN
THE LIVES OF SO MANY YOUNG
PEOPLE. WE WANT TO CELEBRATE MR.
OLMOS LIFETIME OF ACHIEVEMENT,
ALTRUISM, HIS DEDICATION TO
COMMUNITY, AND TO ALL OF US. AND
WE WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
COUNTLESS LIVES THAT HAVE BEEN
CHANGED FOR THE BETTER, THANKS
TO HIS INCREDIBLE WORK AND ALL
THE FOLKS THAT WORK WITH HIM,
INCLUDING ALL OF THOSE HERE IN
THE GALLERY TODAY. MEMBERS AFTER
THIS SESSION, I WANT TO JUST
INVITE YOU AND YOUR STAFFS.
YOU'RE VERY WELCOME TO JOIN ME
IN OUR SENATE CAPITOL ROOM 115.
UPON ADJOURNMENT OF TODAY'S
SESSION WITH THE RECEPTION, TO
HONOR MR. OLMOS AND ALL THE
SPECIAL GUESTS THAT ARE HERE
FROM THE LATINO FILM INSTITUTE
AND THE YOUTH CINEMA PROJECT,
PLEASE JOIN. I KNOW THAT, I KNOW
THAT, MY COLLEAGUE, SENATOR,
ALSO HAS A SOME WORDS TO, TO
SHARE WITH US, BUT I REALLY WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME
TODAY IN EXPRESSING OUR
GRATITUDE AND WELCOMING TO OUR
SENATE FLOOR. THE INCOMPARABLE
EDWARD JAMES OLMOS. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. WE'RE GOING TO TURN NOW
TO SENATOR DURAZO FOR HER
COMMENTS. AS WELL. THANK YOU.
SIR, I WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR
FROM SANTA MONICA VERY MUCH FOR
DOING THIS. IT'S WAY PAST DUE
AND I'M SO PRIVILEGED TO BE ABLE
TO SAY A FEW WORDS ABOUT EDWARD
JAMES OLMOS. LET ME TELL YOU THE
STORY OF ONE ONE OF THE MANY,
MANY LIVES THAT YOU HAVE
CHANGED, IT'S PRETTY VERY
PERSONAL TO ME, OBVIOUSLY. WHILE
IN THE EIGHTH GRADE, MY GRANDSON
GOT CONNECTED TO THE YOUTH
CINEMA PROJECT, AND THAT HAS
COMPLETELY CHANGED HIS LIFE. AND
ONLY A FEW YEARS, THE FILM CLASS
WAS TAUGHT IN THE EIGHTH GRADE.
HE GOT CONNECTED AND FROM THEN
ON HAS BEEN JUST, SO, SO DEVOTED
TO THIS CAREER, THAT I AM JUST
IN AWE, THE EXPERIENCE GAVE HIM
THE CONFIDENCE TO APPLY AND GET
SELECTED AT THE LA COUNTY SCHOOL
OF THE ARTS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
PART OF HIS LIFE. THEN HE BECAME
AN ALUMNI AND CONTINUED ON AT
THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL AS THE
ONLY FRESHMAN IN THAT PARTICULAR
GROUP OF YOUTH. IT GAVE HIM A
REAL CHANCE, NOT AROUND THE
EDGES, BUT TO ACTUALLY GET
INSIDE THE INDUSTRY, AS PART OF
THE YOUTH CINEMA PROJECT, HE
LEARNED WHAT IT TAKES TO MAKE A
MOVIE. AND AS A SENATOR SAID,
EVERYTHING FROM THE SCRIPT TO
THE FILMING TO THE EDITING TO
THE COMPLETION. AND HE'S LEARNED
. NOT LEARNED, COMPLETELY
LEARNED, BUT BEEN EXPOSED TO ALL
ASPECTS OF MAKING A FILM. THE
ONE ON ONE MENTORS WITH WHAT IS
WHAT HE HAS LOVED THE MOST. HE
ACTUALLY GOT ASSIGNED A PROP
MASTER FOR THAT MENTOR, TOOK HIM
AS TOOK HIM TO UNIVERSAL
STUDIOS, WHERE HE WAS EXPOSED TO
THE PROPS. AND THEN WAS ABLE TO
PICK THE PROPS FOR THE FILM. NOW
THIS FILM LATER THIS MONTH, IN A
FEW WEEKS, HIS GROUPS WILL BE
SHOWN ON A QUOTE UNQUOTE RED
CARPET, IMAGINE THE FEELING THAT
HE IS GOING TO EXPERIENCE OF
GOING THROUGH A RED, ON A RED
CARPET, AND SO TODAY, SENECA IS
ATTENDING THE HIGH SCHOOL AND IS
ONE OF THE MANY, MANY LIVES THAT
YOU HAVE CHANGED. AND I WANT TO
PERSONALLY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR WHAT YOU HAVE DEVOTED TO OUR
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU. SENATOR
DURAZO. LET'S SENATOR ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I'D
LIKE TO SHARE A COUPLE OF THINGS
THAT MOST PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
ABOUT OUR HONOREE TODAY IS THE
FACT THAT IF YOU CAN KEEP A
FRIEND FOR A LIFETIME, YOU MUST
BE SOMEONE SPECIAL. WELL, JAY
NOMURA, HIS BEST FRIEND,
JAPANESE AMERICAN. HERE WE HAVE
THE JAPANESE AMERICAN AND
MEXICAN AMERICAN. GROWING UP
SINCE THE THIRD GRADE, I BELIEVE
THEY CAME, BECAME FRIENDS. AND
THAT FRIENDSHIP TO THIS DAY HAS
CONTINUED. THEY'VE BEEN BUSINESS
PARTNERS. THEY WORKED TOGETHER,
ANYTIME YOU'RE IN WHITTIER,
MONTEBELLO, PICO RIVERA,
ANYWHERE YOU SEE JAMES AND YOU
SEE JAY AND MORE. SO I WANT TO
TELL YOU THAT MONTEBELLO LOVES
YOU. WE'RE SO PROUD OF YOU AND
THE ENTIRE LATINO COMMUNITY SAYS
TO ALL OF YOU EVERY TIME YOU GET
HOME. WELCOME HOME. YOU'VE
CERTAINLY MADE US PROUD. GO GET
THEM. THANK YOU
.
WE'D LIKE TO NOW INVITE SENATORS
TO JOIN THE PHOTOGRAPH IN THE
BACK.
OKAY, MEMBERS, LET'S. LET'S GET
GET A LITTLE ORDER HERE, AND WE
CAN MOVE ON WITH OUR BUSINESS ON
THE FLOOR. ALL RIGHT.
CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN. MEMBERS,
I WANT TO NOTE THAT SENATOR
ARCHULETA HAS SOME GUESTS HERE
IN THE GALLERY. LET'S WELCOME
MARY SUE AND GRADUATE STUDENTS
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. PLEASE WELCOME TO
THE SENATE. OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE WITH OUR ORDER OF
BUSINESS HERE ON THE FLOOR.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY SECRETARY. PLEASE READ.
MR. PRESIDENT, I AM DIRECTED TO
INFORM YOUR HONORABLE BODY THAT
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDED AND ON THIS
DAY PASSED, AS AMENDED, SENATE
BILL 233. AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR HONORABLE BODY TO
CONCUR IN SAID AMENDMENTS. SUE
PARKER, CHIEF CLERK OF THE
ASSEMBLY. THANK YOU. THE DESK
WILL NOTE REPORTS OF COMMITTEE
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NEXT TO MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
MEMBERS. WITHOUT OBJECTION, THE
SENATE JOURNAL FOR MAY 6TH, 2024
THROUGH MAY 9TH, 2024 WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. SENATOR PORTANTINO
, THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS, I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RETURN SB 427 TO THE ASSEMBLY
FOR FURTHER ACTION. SO NOTED.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS. THE
FOLLOWING BILL IS REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON RULES. SENATE
BILL 233. PURSUANT TO SENATE
RULE 29.10, D. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE. SECOND READING.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SEN. BILL
1075. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO THIRD READING
MEMBERS. WE HAVE, SEVEN MEMBERS,
SEVEN, SEVEN MEASURES ON THE
AGENDA. LET ME NOTE THEIR
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES. WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN FIRST WITH BILL
ITEM 38. BILL ITEM 38 IS SENATE
BILL 1313. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL 1313 BY SENATOR
ASHBY. AN ACT RELATING TO
VEHICLES. SENATOR ASHBY, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT SB
1313. THE SAFE ROADS ACT. SB
1313 ADDRESSES THE MISUSE OF
SAFETY TECHNOLOGY AND VEHICLES,
PARTICULARLY WITH DRIVING
ASSISTANCE AND MONITORING
SYSTEMS. ADVANCED DRIVING
ASSISTANCE SYSTEMS ARE BECOMING
INCREASINGLY COMMON IN MOTOR
VEHICLES. THEY ALERT DRIVERS OF
DANGEROUS LANE DEPARTURES, LANE
CENTERING AND OF POSSIBLE
OBSTACLES IN THE ROAD.
UNFORTUNATELY DRIVERS ARE
CIRCUMVENTING THESE SAFETY
SYSTEMS BY USING AFTERMARKET AND
HOMEMADE DEVICES DESIGNED TO
SIMULATE A DRIVER'S HANDS ON THE
WHEEL BY APPLYING PRESSURE. SB
1313 PROHIBITS INDIVIDUALS FROM
USING AND PURCHASING DEVICES
DESIGNED TO INTERFERE WITH THE
VEHICLE'S SAFETY MONITORING
SYSTEM. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR ASHBY. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MATTER, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION? THIS MEASURE
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING NO OBJECTION. HOLD
ON 11. ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO
OBJECTIONS. AYES 36. NOES ZERO.
THE MEASURE IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 43 FOLLOWED BY FILE ITEM
48, 59, 61, 73 AND 85. FILE ITEM
43 IS SENATE BILL 1278 BY
SENATOR LAIRD, SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL 1278 BY SENATOR
LAIRD. AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH. SENATOR LAIRD, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. SENATE
BILL 1278 WILL DIRECT THE
GOVERNOR TO ANNUALLY DECLARE
DECEMBER 1ST AS WORLD AIDS DAY
IN CALIFORNIA. IT'S BEEN
OBSERVED INTERNATIONALLY SINCE
1988. IN 2022, THERE'S OVER
142,000 CALIFORNIANS LIVING WITH
AN HIV INFECTION, ACCORDING TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH. WHEN I
WAS THE FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF AN AIDS AGENCY IN
THE 1980S AND THEN 1990S, IT WAS
OUR JOB TO KEEP PEOPLE ALIVE. WE
HAVE DONE THAT NOW. IT'S OUR JOB
TO EDUCATE PEOPLE AND KEEP
INFECTIONS FROM HAPPENING. IT
WOULD BE AN ANNUAL PLATFORM FOR
THIS DISCUSSION. THÀNH I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR LAIRD. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE, THIS
MEASURE IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL WITHOUT
OBJECTIONS. EYES 36 NØ ZERO. THE
MEASURE IS ADOPTED. NEXT UP IS
FILE ITEM 48. THIS IS SCR 104 BY
SENATOR NGUYEN SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 104 BY SENATOR
NGUYEN. RELATIVE TO OLDER
AMERICANS MONTH. SENATOR NGUYEN,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT
SCR 104, WHICH DECLARES THE
MONTH OF MAY 2024 AS OLDER
AMERICANS MONTH OLDER AMERICANS
MONTH CELEBRATES THE LIVES AND
CONTINUED CONTRIBUTION OF OLDER
AMERICANS AND SENIOR CITIZENS.
GROWTH PROJECTIONS FOR THE OLDER
ADULT POPULATION IN THE UNITED
STATES HAVE AFFECTIONATELY
REFERRED TO AS THE INCOMING
SILVER TSUNAMI. CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO OVER 39 MILLION PEOPLE,
AND AROUND 6 MILLION ARE
CONSIDERED OLDER ADULTS OR
SENIOR CITIZENS. RECENT
ESTIMATES SHOW THAT THAT NUMBER
WILL CONTINUE TO GROW AT A RATE
THAT OUTPACES THE REST OF THEIR
COUNTRY BY 2030. IN ORANGE
COUNTY ALONE, OLDER AMERICANS
WILL ACCOUNT FOR 30% OF OUR
POPULATION, AND BY 2050, OLDER
AMERICANS WILL ACCOUNT FOR
AROUND 20. 10 MILLION
CALIFORNIANS, WHILE SOCIETY'S
ATTITUDES AND PERCEPTIONS OF
OLDER AMERICANS AND SENIOR
CITIZENS HAVE CHANGED, THERE IS
MUCH. THERE'S STILL MUCH TO BE
DONE AMONG RAISING AWARENESS AND
UNDERSTANDING THIS POPULATION
TODAY, MANY OLDER ADULTS FULFILL
MANY NECESSARY, IMPORTANT ROLES
AND CONTINUE TO BE ONE OF OUR
GREATEST RESOURCES AND ASSET.
THIS RESOLUTION RECOGNIZES MAY
2024 AS OLDER AMERICANS MONTH
AND ENCOURAGE ALL CALIFORNIANS
TO RECOGNIZE AND TREAT ALL OLDER
AMERICANS, ADULTS AND SENIOR
CITIZENS WITH COMPASSION,
RESPECT AND ENCOURAGE THEM TO
PARTICIPATE IN ACTIVITIES IN
THAT CONTRIBUTE TO THEIR HEALTH,
WELFARE, AND HAPPINESS ON BEHALF
OF OUR STATE'S OLDER ADULTS AND
SENIOR CITIZENS, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR NGUYEN. SENATOR WAHAB,
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SCR 104 OLDER
AMERICANS MONTH. THE RISE OF
COST OF LIVING ACROSS THE STATE
AND NATION IS HAVING A PROFOUND
IMPACT ON AGING ADULTS. SENIORS
ARE THE FASTEST GROWING HOMELESS
POPULATION. THERE ARE CHALLENGES
SEEKING AND AFFORDING MEDICAL
CARE ARE INCREASED BY THEIR
HOUSING INSTABILITY. IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE FUND OUR
SOCIAL SAFETY NETS AND
INCREASING IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING, AS WELL AS METHODS TO
MAINTAIN HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
AND HOUSING STABILITY. IT'S NOT
ONLY A MATTER OF DIGNITY, BUT
ECONOMICS, KEEPING PEOPLE HOUSED
CREATES LESS PRESSURE ON ALL OF
OUR SYSTEMS AND PROMOTES HEALTH
AND WELLNESS. AS WE HONOR OLDER
AMERICANS TODAY, I ASK YOU ALL
TO CONSIDER HOW YOU ARE ACTIVELY
SUPPORTING POLICIES THAT WILL
ENSURE THEIR DIGNITY, HEALTH,
AND HOUSING. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION? MEMBERS
SEEING NONE. SENATOR NGUYEN, YOU
MAY CLOSE. I JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. ANY OBJECTION? SEEING
NONE. AYES 36 NOES ZERO ON THE
RESOLUTION. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NEXT TO FILE ITEM 59. THIS IS SB
1352 BY SENATOR WAHAB.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1352 BY SENATOR WAHAB. AN
ACT RELATING TO CONTINUING CARE
RETIREMENT COMMUNITIES. SENATOR
WAHAB, THANK YOU COLLEAGUES AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. I RISE TO
PRESENT SB 1352, WHICH IS ABOUT
PROTECTING CIVIL RIGHTS IN
CONTINUING CARE COMMUNITIES.
MANY RESIDENTS OF THESE
COMMUNITIES REMAIN UNAWARE OF
THEIR RIGHTS AND FEEL UNCERTAIN
ABOUT ASSERTING THEM.
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY IS THE UMBRELLA
UNDER WHICH CONTINUING CARE
RETIREMENT COMMUNITIES ARE
LICENSED. RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY HAVE
AN EXPANSIVE AND PROTECTIVE BILL
OF RIGHTS. HOWEVER EXISTING LAW
ONLY REQUIRES RESIDENTS RECEIVE
A COPY OF THE MORE NARROW
CONTINUING CARE RETIREMENT
COMMUNITIES BILL OF RIGHTS WHEN
SIGNING A CONTRACT. SB 1352
SIMPLY REQUIRES CONTINUING CARE,
RETIREMENT COMMUNITIES TO ALSO
PROVIDE A COPY OF THE
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY. BILL OF RIGHTS UPON
SIGNING THEIR CONTRACT. THIS
WILL FORTIFY RESIDENT RIGHTS,
PROMOTE INCLUSIVITY, ENSURE
EQUAL TREATMENT FOR ALL AND
INCREASE RESIDENT SELF-ADVOCACY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE MEMBERS. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THE ON THE
MEASURE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. WITHOUT OBJECTION XYZ
36 NÓ ZERO. ON THE MEASURE,
WE'LL MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 61
BY SENATOR BECKER. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 1395 BY
SENATOR BECKER. AN ACT RELATING
TO HOUSING. SENATOR BECKER, I
THANK YOU. MEMBERS WE ALL KNOW
HERE ABOUT THE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA, BUT WE
DON'T ALWAYS KNOW IS SOMETHING
THAT'S UNIQUE TO CALIFORNIA, IS
THAT 67% OF OUR HOMELESS
POPULATION IS UNSHELTERED, 67%
NATIONALLY. THAT NUMBER IS 20.
IN A STATE LIKE NEW YORK, IT'S
5. AND IT'S ALSO BECOMING
INCREASINGLY DANGEROUS TO BE
UNSHELTERED AND BE HOMELESS.
JOURNAL OF HEALTH AFFAIRS JUST
CAME OUT WITH A STUDY. THE
MORTALITY RATE HAS TRIPLED OVER
THE LAST TEN YEARS. WHAT THIS
BILL WILL DO 1395 THE INTERIM
HOUSING ACT IS CREATE THAT
BRIDGE, CREATE THAT MISSING RUNG
ON THE LADDER BETWEEN BEING
UNSHELTERED AND PERMANENT
HOUSING, WITH THIS, I BELIEVE
THAT WE CAN CREATE MORE LOW COST
HOUSING OFTENTIMES ON GOVERNMENT
LAND AND GET PEOPLE OFF THE
STREETS INTO STABILITY, INTO ONE
ADDRESS WHERE THEY GET SERVICES
AND INTO JOBS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR BECKER. ANY DISCUSSION
ON THIS MATTER ANY FURTHER
DEBATE? SEEING NONE, ITS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
. WITHOUT OBJECTION. AYES 36,
NOES ZERO ON THE MEASURE. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
73. THIS IS SB 981 BY SENATOR
WAHAB. SECRETARY. PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 981 BY SENATOR
WAHAB. ENACT RELATING TO SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS. SENATOR WAHAB
THANK YOU PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. I RISE TO PRESENT SB
981, THE DIGITAL IDENTITY THEFT
ACT IDENTITY THEFT IS OFTEN
ASSOCIATED TO FRAUD. THERE ARE
SOME LAWS IN PLACE FOR CREDIT
CARD THEFT AND FINANCIAL
VIOLATIONS OF INNOCENT PEOPLE,
BUT WE NEED TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
21ST CENTURY CRIMES. SB 981
DEFINES DIGITAL IDENTITY THEFT
AS THE UNAUTHORIZED DISTRIBUTION
OF DIGITIZED SEXUALLY EXPLICIT
IMAGES OR VIDEOS POSTED WITHOUT
THE DEPICTED PERSONS CONSENT.
UPON REPORTING, THE IDENTIFIED
CONTENT WOULD BE TEMPORARILY
BLOCKED AND THE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORM WOULD HAVE 14 DAYS TO
DETERMINE IF THE CONTENT IS
DIGITAL IDENTITY THEFT. IF THE
REPORTED CONTENT IS CONFIRMED TO
BE DIGITAL IDENTITY THEFT,
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS ARE
REQUIRED TO PERMANENTLY BLOCK IT
FROM PUBLIC VIEW. DIGITAL
IDENTITY THEFT, PARTICULARLY
INVOLVING SEXUALLY EXPLICIT
CONTENT, CAUSES SIGNIFICANT HARM
, INCLUDING REPUTATIONAL DAMAGE
AND MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. THE
RECENT CASE OF DIGITALLY
MANIPULATED SEXUALLY EXPLICIT
VIDEOS OF TAYLOR SWIFT
HIGHLIGHTS THE NATURE OF THESE
ISSUES, AND IT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED. VICTIMS, ESPECIALLY
NON-CELEBRITIES, LACK RESOURCES
TO DEFEND THEMSELVES FROM THESE
TYPES OF SEXUALLY VIOLENT
CRIMES. THIS IS ESPECIALLY
PROBLEMATIC FOR MINORS THAT ARE
ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND ENGAGE
THROUGHOUT THE DAY, WITH
POTENTIALLY HARMFUL CONTENT
BEING SHARED, SB 981 PROVIDES
CRUCIAL PROTECTION, PARTICULARLY
FOR YOUNG WOMEN WHO ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY TARGETED BY
UNAUTHORIZED, DIGITIZED,
SEXUALLY EXPLICIT IMAGES,
OFFERING THEM A SHIELD AGAINST
EXPLOITATION AND HARM. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR WAHAB. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE, ITS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL WITHOUT
OBJECTION IS 36 NO ZERO. THE
MEASURE IS ADOPTED. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE FINALLY TO OUR LAST ITEM
ON THE DOCKET TODAY. FILE ITEM
85. THIS IS SENATE BILL 1451 BY
SENATOR ASHBY. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL 1451 BY SENATOR
ASHBY. AN ACT RELATING TO
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS.
SENATOR ASHBY. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF SB 1451, WHICH IS THE
ANNUAL BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
CODE OMNIBUS BILL THAT MAKES
VARIOUS CHANGES TO THE PRACTICE
ACTS OF A NUMBER OF PROGRAMS.
THESE PROGRAMS HAVE ALL RECENTLY
BEEN SUBJECT TO THE COMMITTEE'S
SUNSET REVIEW OVERSIGHT PROCESS.
THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY CONTAINS
PROVISIONS THAT EMPOWER FEMALE
DOMINANT HEALTH PROFESSIONS TO
SAFELY AND SUCCESSFULLY INCREASE
ACCESS TO CARE FOR CALIFORNIA
PATIENTS. WE HAVE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION,
CALIFORNIA DENTAL HYGIENIST
ASSOCIATION, AND VARIOUS OTHER
LICENSED PROFESSIONALS TO ENSURE
ACCESS TO CARE FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ASHBY. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION? THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AYES 36. NOES
ZERO. THE MEASURE CARRIES.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO RETURN
NOW TO. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. THIS IS
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR ADJOURN AND
MEMORIES. WE HAVE TWO MEMBERS
WHO WANT TO ASK FOR THAT
REQUEST. SENATOR UMBERG AND
SENATOR RUBIO WILL BEGIN WITH
SENATOR UMBERG. PLEASE GIVE HIM
YOUR ATTENTION. MEMBERS SENATOR
JONES, PLEASE GIVE SENATOR
UMBERG YOUR ATTENTION. SENATOR
UMBERG, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO HONOR THE
LIFE AND THE MEMORY OF DON
BLANKENSHIP, WHO PASSED AWAY
LAST WEEK. MANY OF YOU KNOW DON
FOR HIS YEARS OF SERVICE IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. HE WAS A DEAR FRIEND
OF MINE AND MANY OTHERS. DON WAS
BORN IN LONG BEACH TO FLOYD
ROBERT BLANKENSHIP AND MARY IDA
RAPP. HE ATTENDED SAINT
ANTHONY'S CATHOLIC SCHOOL, WHERE
HE MET THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE, JAN
ROGERS. THEY WERE MARRIED
SHORTLY AFTER HIGH SCHOOL AND
SHARED 53 YEARS OF MARRIAGE. DON
ATTENDED LONG BEACH STATE AND
EARNED A DEGREE IN CRIMINAL
JUSTICE WHILE SERVING IN THE AIR
FORCE. HE BEGAN HIS CAREER IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT AT LOS ALAMITOS
POLICE DEPARTMENT AND LATER
TRANSFERRED TO THE SANTA ANA
POLICE DEPARTMENT, WHERE HE
SERVED FROM 1975 TO 1999, WHERE
HE WOULD RETIRE FROM SANTA ANA
POLICE DEPARTMENT AS A SERGEANT
AND PRESIDENT OF THE SANTA ANA
POLICE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION. HE
THEN BECAME THE CHIEF OF THE
BUREAU OF INVESTIGATION AT THE
ORANGE COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE UNTIL HIS
RETIREMENT IN 2009. DON HAD A
PASSION FOR HONORING HIS FALLEN
BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN, LAW
ENFORCEMENT, WHO DIED IN THE
LINE OF DUTY. HE SERVED AS THE
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS
MEMORIAL FOUNDATION'S SECOND
PRESIDENT DURING HIS MORE THAN
20 YEARS OF DEDICATED SERVICE TO
THE FOUNDATION, HE DEDICATED HIS
LIFE TO THE PROTECTION OF THE
SERVICE OF ALL OF US. HE WAS A
PROUD MEMBER OF SANTIAGO DE
COMPOSTELA CATHOLIC CHURCH IN
LAKE FOREST, WAS A FOURTH DEGREE
MEMBER OF THE KNIGHTS OF
COLUMBUS. HE ENJOYED SPENDING
TIME WITH HIS FAMILY, TRAVELING
THE WORLD, WORKING OUT. HE
WORKED OUT ALMOST EVERY DAY
NOTRE DAME FOOTBALL,
VOLUNTEERING AT CHURCH AND
SPENDING TIME IN HIS BACKYARD
WITH HIS FRIENDS. AND HE LOVED
ALL DOGS. HE WAS A DEVOTED
HUSBAND, FATHER, GRANDFATHER,
LOYAL FRIEND TO ALL WHO KNEW
HIM. HE WILL BE DEARLY MISSED,
THOSE OF US WHO KNEW HIM CAN AND
WILL FOREVER REMEMBER THE SOUND
OF HIS VOICE AND THE SOUND OF
HIS LAUGHTER, AS WELL AS JAN,
HIS WIFE'S. THE SOUND OF HER
VOICE THAT RESONATES RESONATES
WITH ALL WHO WHO KNEW HIM. HE IS
PREDECEASED BY HIS MOTHER AND
HIS FATHER AND IS SADLY HIS. HIS
WIFE, JAN PREDECEASED HIM. SHE
DIED JUST A FEW YEARS AGO. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS CHILDREN CARRIE
LEE PLUSH HUSBAND JAMES PLUSH
STACY LYNN PERCEK, HUSBAND
MATTHEW PERSIC, DONALD WAYNE
BLANKENSHIP, HIS WIFE TIFFANY
BLANKENSHIP AND HIS FOUR
GRANDCHILDREN, WHO HE WAS
IMMENSELY PROUD OF. JULIA JAMES,
MADELYN MARIE, MASON, ROBERT,
AND LILY GRACE. I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN THE STATE SENATE IN HIS
MEMORY TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR UMBERG. THE SENATE
EXTENDS ITS CONDOLENCES TO THE
BLANKENSHIP FAMILY AND MANY
FRIENDS. PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO HE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED IN THE SENATE
JOURNAL, AND THAT WE MAY ADJOURN
IN HIS MEMORY. NEXT, I'D LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE, TODAY I
RISE WITH GREAT SADNESS TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF MONTE
MONTENEGRO FROM BALDWIN PARK.
BORN UMBERTO MONTENEGRO, TO HIS
FATHER JESUS AND MOTHER CARMEN
ON CATALINA ISLAND IN THE CITY
OF AVALON ON MARCH 20TH, 1929.
HIS FATHER WAS PART OF THE
WORKFORCE THAT BUILT THE ICONIC
CASINO IN AVALON. MONTE WENT TO
A MILITARY HIGH SCHOOL WHERE HE
PARTICIPATED IN THE DRUM AND
BUGLE CORPS, WHERE HE PLAYED IN
THE MARCHING BAND AND THE LAST
FEW YEARS OF HIS LIFE, MONTE
ENJOYED PLAYING A SNARE DRUM ON
HIS PATIO. AFTER HIGH SCHOOL, HE
MET THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE, ANNA.
HE PROMISED TO MARIANA, BUT WITH
ONE CONDITION SOMETHING THAT HE
NEEDED TO DO FIRST. HE ENLISTED
IN THE MARINE CORP AND WENT OFF
TO FIGHT FOR HIS COUNTRY,
SERVING HIS FOUR YEARS WITH
TOURS IN KOREA, NORTH AFRICA AND
MOROCCO, AND FINISHING UP IN
BROOKLYN, NEW YORK. MONTE WAS A
PROUD MARINE AND I OFTEN REFER
TO HIM AS MY FAVORITE MARINE. HE
WORE THE UNIFORM WITH PRIDE, AND
I'VE NEVER SEEN HIM FIGHT AS
HARD AS HE DID WHEN HE WAS
FIGHTING TO ERECT A MONUMENT TO
HONOR ALL THE VETERANS IN OUR
COMMUNITY, HE GOT SUPPORT FROM
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC DOLLARS, AND
HE WAS ABLE TO COMPLETE IT. HE
ALWAYS STOOD PROUD AND SALUTED
HIS VETERAN HEROES. HE WORE HIS
UNIFORM WITH HONOR AND HAD GREAT
RESPECT FOR ALL THOSE THAT SERVE
THIS COUNTRY. MONTE EMBODIED THE
WORDS HONOR, COURAGE, AND
LOYALTY. MONTE AND HIS BEAUTIFUL
WIFE, ANNA BOUGHT THEIR FIRST
HOUSE IN BALDWIN PARK AND
STARTED THEIR FAMILY. IT WAS A
FAMILY OF SERVICE. ANA
MONTENEGRO SERVED OUR COMMUNITY
AS THE ELECTED TREASURER FOR
OVER 30 YEARS, AND THEY'RE
CURRENTLY BUILDING A PARK NAMED
AFTER HER, WHICH WOULD HONOR HER
MEMORY AS WELL. MONTE WAS A
PROUD FATHER OF FIVE, AND WITH
AND WITH THE SUPPORT AND
ENCOURAGEMENT OF HIS WIFE ANNA,
HE ENROLLED IN MOUNT SAINT
ANTONIO COLLEGE. WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY STUDYING TO BE AN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTOR. IN 1965,
HE STARTED MONTE'S ELECTRIC,
WHERE HE SPENT 57 YEARS SERVING
OUR COMMUNITY, AND HIS CUSTOMERS
INCLUDED THE CITY OF BALDWIN
PARK, PARKS AND RECREATION, CITY
YARD, AND THE POLICE DEPARTMENT.
MONTE ALWAYS PARTICIPATED IN
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORTED AND
HELPED THOSE MOST DISADVANTAGED
STAGED. MONTE RECRUITED AND
TRAINED MANY OF OUR YOUTH AND
WAS PROUD TO SEE THEM SUCCEED IN
THE ELECTRICAL FIELD. MONTE
BELIEVED IN HIS COMMUNITY, HE
AND HIS BELOVED BALDWIN PARK,
AND AT THE YOUNG AGE OF 93.5
YEARS OLD, MONTE STOPPED GETTING
IN HIS SERVICE TRUCK AND MAKING
SERVICE CALLS. MONTE LIVED A
LIFE OF SERVICE, SERVING HIS
COUNTRY, HIS COMMUNITY K¾T HIS
VFW, WHICH HE SPENT DAYS
SUPPORTING, AND ANYONE WHO
CALLED TO MONTE WAS THERE.
SENATE-TV COLLEAGUES, PLEASE
HELP ME IN REMEMBERING THE LIFE
OF THIS INCREDIBLE MAN WHO WAS A
STAPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY. MONTE
WILL BE MISSED. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. SENATOR RUBIO.
THE SENATE EXTENDS ITS
CONDOLENCES TO THE MONTENEGRO
FAMILY AND MANY FRIENDS. PLEASE
BRING HIS NAME FORWARD SO WE CAN
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED IN THE
SENATE JOURNAL, AND THAT WE MAY
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY IF THERE
IS NO OTHER BUSINESS BEFORE THE
SENATE. SENATOR GROVE, THE DESK
IS CLEAR. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. GOOD JOB TODAY,
COLLEAGUES. OUR NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS THURSDAY, 9 A.M. MAY
16TH, 2024. THE SENATE WILL BE
IN RECESS UNTIL 3:30 P.M, AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE. WE WILL
RECONVENE THURSDAY, MAY 16TH AT
9 A.M.